The myths are real
they have an ancient rivalry
there was a war
and they're the last ones standing
godzilla will come for him
there can't be two alpha titans who
bows to who? Kong bows to no one
the world needs Kong
there is something provoking them into war
I made a promise to protect her he did the same
the world needs him
These are dangerous times we need kong the world
needs him two of these classic monsters are going
head-to-head that's really so exciting it is
a spectacle it's unlike anything you've ever
seen but the beauty of this particular story
is the different storylines of every character
he needs our help there must be some way to
disorient godzilla you can look at the film as
two separate stories that intersect eventually
team kong and team godzilla each human story is
following the monster story as well we believe
that they have an ancient rivalry the myths say
that their ancestors fought each other in a great
war team kong you have alexander skarsgard kaylee
hoddle and rebecca hall they're there really
to support kong and his fight with godzilla the
stakes are high and it's a very risky operation
but we have to go through with it all right mad hatter
down the rabbit hole on the other end of the
journey we have team godzilla millie bobby
brown brian tyree henry and julian dennison
they're basically on this adventure to try
find out why godzilla is attacking they're
trying to put two and two together to figure out
why is this going on they're an amazing team they
complement each other so well to be a part of that
team is great just trying to figure out how to
actually understand godzilla rather than trying
to destroy him we always saw the movie as being
separated between team godzilla and team kong
and that was exciting to me doing this movie
team kong or godzilla i'm a kong guy i don't
know i got a root for kong hard for me to
choose but as a japanese person godzilla
I like king kong because he's a giant monkey and
monkey's cool 100% team Kong i'm not picking sides
you don't really want to pick a side you kind
of gotta pick a side team godzilla all the way.
Welcome back everyone this is going to be
my brand new godzilla vs kong trailer video
there's a whole bunch of new footage a whole bunch
more mechagodzilla so i'll break that down too
and obviously they're talking a little bit more
about the history of the monster verse in these
new monsterverse films so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
i will be doing all the normal videos that i would
do easter eggs and talking about the ending of the
film in the future the monster verse because they
have talked about renewing their deal with touhou
so it does sound like we're going to get more
godzilla and more kong films in the universe but
just starting with the mechagodzilla stuff first
so it opens with a much more prominent version of
the mechagodzilla scene of him attacking the
city and everyone running down the staircase
underneath him but you notice that they've
actually polished the visual effects way more
so now you can actually see mechagodzilla's chest
light up with his energy while he's attacking
there was the digital readout of his systems and
that other apex scene we saw earlier it gives us
read out of his charge level the power levels
because he's mechanical you literally have to
charge him like he runs on the biggest batteries
you've ever seen they also seemingly confirmed
that the walter simmons character is behind apex
or in charge of apex because you see him walking
around inside this big room with all the readouts
behind him and the screens that look exactly like
this other digital readout of mechagodzilla
like whatever's going on in here this is the
room where they're controlling mechagodzilla and
in this other milly bobby brown scene in one of
those clips you actually see her standing next to
this screen and you look behind her and you can
actually see a digital readout of mechagodzilla's
tail all lit up it seems like they're implying
that team godzilla either breaks into apex's
facility where they're controlling mechagodzilla
or they get captured by apex and they just wind
up inside this control room but they also hype up
that the human storyline team godzilla and team
kong also kind of flows with the same storyline
of godzilla and khan going at each other early in
the film like they spend most of the film fighting
each other but then later it's implied that they
work together or somehow help each other take down
mechagodzilla and the same kind of thing happens
with teen kong and team godzilla like they're both
kind of working at odds with each other trying
to figure out what's going on because most of
the films they don't know what's happening with
mechagodzilla they just think that godzilla's gone
crazy so team kong is trying to help him defeat
godzilla so they can save the world or so they
think then team godzilla millie bobby brown's team
is trying to find out what's going on with apex
in the artificial version of godzilla but then by
the end of the film they wind up working together
just as the two titans godzilla and kong wind up
working together depending on what the actual end
of the movie winds up being like no idea how many
of these actors would wind up showing up in the
next sequel movie whatever that winds up being i
know because they're hyping up all these ancient
war of the monsters maybe they're building up
to their own version of avengers infinity war
and avengers end game like the marvel movies
like another brand new war of the monsters
so to speak but you've also probably seen some
of the promo art for mechagodzilla too because
even though we get all these different shots of
him in these trailers like you see him you don't
really get the full reveal in any of these scenes
so this is kind of what his design is meant to
look like and you can kind of see what they're
trying to do with this modern iteration of the
design like the classic designs for mechagodzilla
or like mechagador or the other mecha versions of
the titans look more like the original versions
with just metal skin on top of them whereas the
modern redesigns are trying to be a little bit
more practical with the way they make them look
so if someone in modern day like elon musk
wanted to spend a trillion dollars building
an artificial version of mechagodzilla this is
closer to what it might feel like they've done
similar things with the modern redesigns of kong
and godzilla as well like the reason why it seems
like godzilla has so much junk in his trunk is
because practically his body has to carry around
so much weight he would literally have to have the
world's biggest caboose relative to his upper body
otherwise his entire body would just collapse
under the weight of itself that's also why the
new version of kong doesn't spend a whole lot of
time walking around totally upright with perfect
human posture because he's so top heavy it doesn't
look like he totally skipped leg day or anything
like that he would lope around on all fours like
you would expect a primate too there's a whole
bunch of new footage of them capturing kong
carrying him in that giant web of netting and
helicopters to their fake version of the hollow
earth underground like you see him falling there
into whatever facility they've created for him him
suddenly realizing everything's not quite right
then pulling the biggest truman show you've ever
seen realizing that it's all fake and just throws
the tree right through the barrier like how dare
you we've learned a little bit more about brian
tyree henry's character you might remember him
from spider-man into the spider-verse he played
miles morales father during that so his voice
might sound familiar but he also showed up in
the joker movie too so you've probably seen him
at least somewhere in the last couple of years
but i believe his character is supposed to have
formally worked for apex and then left their
organization just because they seem like they were
too shady but from the trailer footage it doesn't
seem like he totally understands what's going on
with mechagodzilla but maybe he's the one that
clues them into the idea that apex was harvesting
titan dna and just messing with their biology
and i believe the whole idea behind mechagodzilla
is that apex actually used the carcass from king
ghidorah to develop mechagodzilla like after
godzilla kills king ghidorah at the end of
godzilla king of monsters his carcass is left
lying there on the battlefield i think the theory
is that apex was able to steal one of ghidorah's
heads and just use it to reverse engineer their
own titan which becomes mechagodzilla and the
reason why he doesn't look exactly like godzilla
like it's not an exact copy is because it's based
on ghidorah's head not godzilla's head so it's
also a bit of a reference to mecca ghidorah
which is an actual character from the classic
touhou films but in the context of the movie
like the toys they're going to be selling all
the merchandise it is the mechagodzilla character
it just there's a lot of godora that influences
the design of mechagodzilla who knows if we'll
see future mecha versions of the titans in any
of the new monsterverse films i feel like you can
only do so many of those in the new films without
it starting to feel too ridiculous like where are
people getting all the money to create these it
would cost trillions and trillions of dollars to
build something like this and i believe the whole
reason for the creation of mechagodzilla like the
whole reason why apex is doing this is because
they want to get rid of the titans fearing that
they're going to destroy the world like they're
all about human supremacy the age of humans
whereas you have this whole idea of the ancient
cultures of the world worshiping the titans as
their protectors like the protectors of the earth
not just humanity they kind of got into that
during king of monsters the idea that the titans
godzilla particularly bring balance to the world
between nature and humans and i also love the
idea that as we've gotten on in the sequels to the
monster verse films they slowly and slowly beefed
up the titan parts of the storylines like more and
more of the movies themselves are about the titans
and less and less about the human storylines
because who are we kidding here godzilla kong
they're like the real stars of the movie so the
movie's dropping on hbo max and in theaters on
the same day march 31st so depending on where you
live you might also be able to go see it in an
actual movie theater so as long as you stay safe
i would recommend you see it on the biggest screen
possible just because that was the way the
movie was made to be seen on a giant screen
and hopefully after the movie comes out they'll
start talking about the future of the monster
verse films i think they have a broad idea of
where they're headed with these but i would love
to see them build up to a big giant war of the
monsters if they can pull that off or at least
destroy her i feel like he would be like their
version of thanos inside this universe like who
would be the ultimate big bad of the monster verse
universe if not him and even though it's kind of
funny to think about it this way it's technically
true really humans are meant to be the actual
villain of these monsterverse films but if you
have any big questions or any easter eggs that
you noticed in this trailer footage that i didn't
talk about in the video just write them below in
the comments big reminder too the justice league
snyder cut is being released on thursday i'll
be doing videos for that and falcon and winter
soldier episode 1 is out on friday and i'll be
doing videos for that every week too for all the
episodes make sure you have alerts enabled for my
channel so you don't miss any of those everyone
click here for that last really big falcon and
winter soldier trailer and click here for that
brand new spider-man 3 no way home teaser trailer
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!